[Musik]
wie fast stoischen einer meister braucht
hatte die erste frau in der kabinen und
zwei wochen schlechter ist frühster
kindheit schwerstbehinderte bruder die
schaanerin infektion völlig unerwartet
innerhalb von stunden gestorben
[Musik]
ich würde aber sie bleibe richtig finden
die eher trauriger moment die
schicksalsschläge haben wir gezeigt was
wirklich ist und ich glaube all das hat
mich reifer gemacht hat mich weniger
weniger zum träumen lassen sondern
einfach möglich zeigte das ist realität
[Musik]
nach zwei wirklich glückliche jahres
immer noch linie in der krise gerutscht
irgendeine chance so groß wurde das werk
merkt an das geht nicht ohne training
[Musik]
ich habe mich extrem lang in der leere
dosen gefüllt doch deutlich denn
irgendeinen immer wissen wo sie kurz mit
ihm schluss eigentlich schlau was ist
wichtig im leben was sind überhaupt nur
lebenserwartung das sind lebensziel und
vor dem hexagon ich mich nie nach einer
haben
der trainings sitzt auch der luft mal
audi jährige nur fußes glücklicher täter
beim werkstoffs mal was einfällt wenn es
nimmer hätte und mehr realisieren was
man falsch gemacht und je länger je mehr
merkmale division immer noch mehr man
wirklich seiner bürger
[Musik]
das ist die dritte piste
und ich glaube reiter muss viele
kompromisse
[Musik]
am anfang sind immer zweifel da also
meine nach hat sich zwar dreidimensional
auf meinem computer eine schaurige wie
das kleine durch sehen wie sich das
rennen entwickelt
aber ich meine dem moment wo wir jetzt
vor sondern wachsen und vielleicht nur
alles voll mit fisch dann haben wir sich
gut vorstellen dass sich mit 200 meter
flach laufe lediglich das rennen nicht
bringen
es sind sehr oft ein buch entscheid wenn
es mich hinter die reduzierten muss ich
mein gefühl folgende muss ich muss ich
sagen okay ich muss über rechts oder
links das ist vielleicht kommt jetzt
springen
aber es sehe nach rechts
überhaupt von der familie jährige ruhe
für sich selber
auf der maxi ist im beruf im ring
fahrerkabine und das hat eigentlich
bespitzele angefangen dass ich ein leben
lang immer angst um ihre minimalist
gegenteil von ihm hatte ich sie auf die
rente sieht er hätte sie sich nicht
hundertprozentig wohngefühl die der
berge sich aus dem flachland köflach
ländlichen krieg das vergisst und flach
schlank sie aber sie hätten noch nie
ängstlich da wenn zum wenn zum berger
gegangen ist wenn es um schnell gegangen
ist wenn es frauen im sport gegangen ist
also absolut mit gibt sie für das zepter
im 56
[Musik]
ich habe zwei politiker alle zwei jahre
ich spüre dass schon heute genau das ist
unheimlich stolz dass meine familie
kommt
vor allem brüder sind das team also das
team insofern dass man nicht immer
miteinander gestritten untereinander wie
der honig mehr und eigentlich so bald
das lachen können mitmachen alles
miteinander gemacht
ich auch sehr schnell gemerkt dass ich
gut bin zuerst ihren kunden in der
ersten klasse hatte ich im ziel gesehen
als richter aber ich habe gewisse das
ist grunder will sich massen stark sein
sagte zwanziger auf einer linie alle
miteinander weg und pia bach und
hattenheimer wollen in der heimat 47
großartig sehen die alle die grund und
boden gefahren und anja norweger
brauchen keine effektiven oder wie
gebracht und das machen wir nicht
das heißt noch gar nicht nur die letzte
tor hütete schnell schief durchaus
stellen wieder der bluetooth von
projekten und komplettieren den moment
natürlich zweimal verloren hat und wie
die kunden
[Musik]
eine stelle ist natürlich besonders sie
von der familie ganz flamini eltern auch
für minijobber wiederum für mich gesetzt
dieses fürchterliche wo so klappten
können auch für spiele notwendig was wir
tätig sind oft operieren und der kurse
unfall passiert was genau im detail
passiert ist dass ich das haben wir
jährlich die größe das netz sich nach
der narkose einfach macht
[Musik]
das ist ein schwieriger schritt für die
sga will ich weiß dass du das natürlich
automatisch der übrigen werden wir nicht
das kalte dass ich immer so
ich höre überhaupt wenn ich mich
probiere selbst zu der art von problem
kümmert du musst nur gern verdrängen und
die hintergrund rücken und dort sich
einfach mehr auf duft situation weil
mein gott
im vordergrund steht konzentrieren
[Musik]
danke
so mancher geordnet und das geht mir
hier aufpassen
[Musik]
ich habe zumal nach wie vor der schutz
vor richtig und ich mir sehr sicher
relativ schnell verleiht habe ich habe
ich probiert schätzen dass ich das
schicksal akzeptiert als müssen
akzeptieren
[Musik]
es ist meine schwester und und mehr
erwartet vielleicht ist im moment dass
man viel viel viel mehr für garten
filter wurde
aber wenn man ihre situation ruft seine
dramen erklärt der mit uns
ich glaube dass es ein model im gurt sie
hätte fantastischen betrügt wo sie sie
erlebt hat ihre eigene welt wie die welt
das weiß ich nicht das kann mehr
angezeigt
[Musik]
das verhältnis von mensch und natur muss
im august liche sind also
grundvoraussetzung ist dass die mensch
natur grundsätzlich sorgt aber ob
gesorgt regen mit betretungsverbot
gemacht werden oder nicht dass das ziel
viele spezial
ich glaube dass natur da ist dass die
menschliche natur ziel und darf halte
dass sich das bewegen der fried was auch
immer willkommen allerseits
an diesem schönen tag heute
konzentrieren wir uns auf die abfahrt
ich glaube das gehört olympischen
spielen natürlich dass es mag nur hand
wo von mir ist total übertrieben ich
stehe die große anlage dass das immer
größer dass immer mehr
das ist ganz harmlos um die entwicklung
ich habe anfang approbiert dritte lösung
zu finden
die einzige in dem das mit pisten oder
im beruf der hand sagt mir verzichtet
ruf und deren frauen und man auf der
gleichen stelle vor
das wollten wir nicht zu machen das ist
ehrlich holz es gab wohl ein
missverständnis
ich wollte den grad absinken so dass wir
hier acht meter in der breite haben
über sprache ja selbstverständlich
meistens also ich muss ja mit mimt
deutsche denker märz englisches recht
lecker muss das auf englisch probierens
kommunizieren der was im pfad muss das
englisch erstens verstehe aber auch
thematisch es ist nun ziemlich schwierig
ist erklärt wer der boss almunia
skipiste gesehen
ganz wichtige person in meiner karriere
ist adele von bicsi und zwar nicht als
bundesrat oder der als nationalrat
sondern als bickel hertha-coach im c
kader nehmen wir schliefen hätte schütze
segment sie sich die besten für zwei
drei situationen cavani mehr als chef
ganz klar und hält mit jedem interesse
haben ihr zugesetzt
es geht ja die spezielle geschichte
zwischen folk und des kandidaten mit
damals sind wir sind natürlich
kandidaten hans kröger das möchte ich
noch nie gesehen würde mich und ich habe
mein klagen vielfahrer können wir sind
schockiert bis mit einer gewissen status
ist ein nachmittag zum wie man könne sie
trainiere zum zum konditionstraining
denn sie sich rohr nach der hauptstrom
der hauptcharakter der western über den
trainingsanzug der anderen hinterher
heimische trage anderen also man hat
gespürt verständnis
hätten zwei team gemacht eine oper ein
staffellauf weg dorthin und hexen nicht
sprechen so einen charakter also eine
helle mütze mit handy der schnee
damit ist der charakter faire und so
haben wir darunter eine staffel laufen
müssen und das schon über ich bin
einfach die distanz die ist 40 bis 50
eingefroren und hat das wirklich
allerletzte blödsinn gefunden
und wenn sie mir nach der tortur zurück
jetzt da der nächste positioniert sein
land seit jahren eine domäne mit deiner
nächsten ecke segelt und fragte wer denn
die platz nicht leer
der catcher shaq attack seien im prinzip
ja schon recht ich glaube das könnte sie
das kind genau zu entscheiden dass sie
wo es weiter bringt
wer im sibirischen sich die
qualifikation für mich ist der
karrierehöhepunkt im heidekreis klares
ziel kann aber und das ist alles
entscheiden wie sich im inneren ihre
frühe karriere immer der traum mit laufe
immer dass der den magischen moment das
den magischen moment wirken ein stadt
passiere vor dem muss mit träumen davon
ich meine es hat denn so alles zeichnet
sturm und ist einfach unglaublich
ich glaube das ist drei stärkere moment
gegen ihrer karriere als die
zieldurchfahrt in köthen einfach wird
umstand ideal gesehen wenn du mit nummer
15 ins ziel und alle worte sind dünne
durch zieht dann weiter bis jetzt sicher
bis großes passiert wird sicher bis
verrücktes passiert
[Musik]
die märkte tragisch ich eigentlich dass
sie war dann halt die ganze der ganze
zirkus angefangen hat für mich jeder
schweiz
sie sind ja nicht nur drei familien sie
haben die einer größeren wie und was
leistet die bereits im skisport nation
staunt dass sie sogar ihre familie
leaderposition vermögen ich habe zwei
brüder steve mitfahrer einen investor
manfred werde ich bereits bekommen
überhaupt geklappt hat und daran werde
ich sie bezeichnen das werde ich im
junioren nachwuchs kabel
[Musik]
bruder manfred schließlich bewies zum
schluss dass man bei rossis nicht nur
skifahren kann
[Musik]
[Applaus]
während sehr viel mit einer und
trainiert meistens im gamestar proben
miteinander ist der jugendsender fahrer
noch die regional recht verständlich dem
man auch immer der renner sind gegen
einen fahrer bezüglich man für muss ich
am anfang auf wie man die relativ noch
zuwächse sehen und her körperlich
stärker und sich alle register ich
glaube der beste skifahrer ob sie nicht
besser hat lädt sie eigentlich
körperlich viel fixer und sich immer sie
mir eigentlich für stoffgleiche häufig
sie mit - zwei jahre vorsprung
und darum hat das natürlich schon
politiker
[Applaus]
die dem moment wo er explodierte vor dem
mann daraufhin auf währungs- und schloss
nur 0 36
[Musik]
ich frage auch drei kommen der
gesundheit sollten sich die
weltmeisterschaft und riesig sein
die olympiadritte aber dass wir später
noch alkohol
das ist das ist schon verrückt für die
gestartet eigentlich ganz hoch in den
anden erheblichen gehen hätte die liga
voraussetzungen hätte sogar die licher
talent wenn nicht sogar aufs hütte nur
herr miteinander sich und den driftet
auseinander
der eine sieht dann ist natürlich auch
ein bewies was leben überhaupt hat halt
machen
für mich bedeutet es trachten wunder
wurde fertiggestellt werden
wahrscheinlich
selbstverständlich haben wir sehr viel
dazu beitragen
selbstverständlich haben die flüsse und
uns mit störe aber wenn halt denn
irgendwie hin diesmal im blick dass wir
miteinander denn jetzt alles steril und
den denkt vergisst aber gleich wieder
falsche weg und meistens nur zurück
[Musik]
immer wieder wird immer wieder da sie
ihren fans brauchen der weiß das aber
ich bin immer da wenn er mich berührt
[Musik]
und erledigt der tsg niefern pusht sehr
gern musik ich als installierte vor ihm
am meisten profitieren sie 2x
informieren und herrisch eigentlich der
verrückte voran er ist der lustigste war
keine sehen ist das theaterspielen macht
das leben schwer gemacht und
anschließend noch mehr irgend eines
tages per telefon die musik im spital
und die hinterachse spital und heimberg
seite heike bakterien entdeckt wo es
genau ist aber innerhalb von einem tag
anderthalb bis er ganz gesunde mensch
spital eingeliefert worden
[Musik]
es ist klar dass nach goethe nach dem
weltmeister natürlich klappt an hängend
die olympischen spiele focus rose wenn
man vor dem baguette hat den habe ich
auch sei das so ja zuerst muss ich mich
qualifizieren denn museum fall durch ko
und dann wäre es doch schön wenn man die
medaille nachher wird die olympischen
spiele des erstaunens bietet dafür das
zeige dass henry heißt es ein
olympiasieg
[Musik]
ich wollte mehr machen ich muss nie
machen als wenn sie im training kaiser
50 liegestützen ich immer eine 510 810
jemand gemerkt denn die hier angebracht
wenn es kaiser hätten wir machen
ich trainiere typ 2 läuft slalom läuft
und nach zwei slalom läuft heizkreis wir
können die zahlen an tour ab dann kann
ich irgendwie ein grund gefunden dass
ich nur ein schuh fertigen die anja
krüger zappa oder irgendwas vergessen
und bin nur eine schufa als auch der
olympia laufen welle machen
[Musik]
bei olympischen spielen oder so viele
äpfel
[Applaus]
[Musik]
die leiden des trainer und funktionär
wie schneller etwa 113 würde ich sagen
hat der passiert
ferner tritt jetzt im zielschuss fremde
webseiten 53 und das design neuer
bestzeit in 1 51 43 1 51 43 klar in
führung gegangen
mit jedem modernen um stark sich von ich
denke er hat der arzt jetzt warten wir
ab wie lange die fabrik sicher und
schnell fast unerträglich wurden fast
noch eine stufe bis er endlich über die
ziellinie gemerkt dass wir jetzt aber
nicht weg sie wohl jetzt wendet oder
zielraum krause tisch und und alles
verändere es auch lilien innere
zufriedenheit genosse sich an dass sie
angst weltmeisterschaft mit der spontane
freude sei und dass das rundet das ich
dann auch erst später als nolympia sieht
wirklich bedeutet das merkst du
eigentlich erst in den nachfolgenden
jahren vor allem vor allem erst nach der
karriere
die olympischen spiele von sapporo
brachten der schweiz eine schöne
bescherung
ich habe nach den olympischen spielen
sowie die spielerische leichtigkeit an
der spitze verloren
aber ich glaube ich bin hier besser ski
fahren recht plötzlich für kitzbühel der
kunde hat bin ich kenne ja viel besser
ski fahren als wie der vorhergehende ja
aber mit wenig zu wenig intuition ich
die ganze die ganzen spielerische
leichtigkeit an ich vermisse beiden
bleiben aber ausgerechnet im vw tiguan
ist wirklich gemerkt langsamer die
technisch wäre piste herr typische easy
gepusht und im material das ist absolut
perfekt
ich habe ja ich habe mein vater besucht
im spittaler schwer krank sie der arzt
hat mir auf wie vor die ihnen keine
beziehung hätten zeitlos völlig bedient
hatte verabschieden und den zusätzlich
will ich gar nicht gab
auf das kitzbüheler und ich berlin
gekommen und danach wie wenn ein
milligramm kaiser hat die hätte zeitlos
macht keine gedanken macht er keine
sorge mir geht's okay ich überhaupt kein
problem
du musst mir einfach die abfahrt gründe
aber durch mini motivation gewaltig tour
gegangen bedeuten einfach gefahren
jenseits von gut und böse ich habe
probiert die darsteller 80 relativ lang
in der haut kleben und aufgestanden wie
hat es mir ab und dann bin ich auch
druckluft lotus ganzes überflogen äbte
dorfen b durch takeda zu tun
durch diverse lieder und dem wie nie
wieder zurück piste aber natürlich
bereits zwei turbos klaren probiert
anzuschauen
ein paar steigern während rossi hat die
einfahrten steigern nicht erwischt sie
haben das ganz kurz geändert und die
wiederholung bernadotte erwischt die
einfahrt in den steilhang nicht und
stürzte russia ausgeschieden
ich meine wenn man ein wunsch für sich
selber zu gründen denn nicht das heißt
den haben wir die medaille wenn es nicht
gelinge aber wenn der wunsch so groß
wird dass man ein foto ihres abschieds
klingt
ich glaube dann können dann gehts
übermäßige kraft und dann ist man immer
realistisch und dann machen wir einfach
mal will ich nicht also zweimal
[Musik]
wenn ich in vancouver fahrer meistens
sicher dass früh am morgen
denn wiederholt sich das anders sein
wenn sich genau gleiche immer nicht so
wie der rennfahrer ist immer möglich
immer nur bereit gleich viel risiko xk
wir damals für ihn zählt immer noch
genau das gleiche wie damals als ich
nicht siegprämie zählt es ist der erfolg
schon geht's allen wir haben nur zwei
fahrer am start
denen geht es gut direkt bereit
ich bin immer nur extrem bitte sachen
springs irgendwie an der backe
schnittigen neutraler sie ja weniger
mehr verändern aber ich habe heute nur
die beklemmende angst in der abfahrt los
geht das bis ganz ganz schlimmes
passiert das restrisiko die recht
verstehe ich immer nur mir ihnen genau
gleich oder vielleicht sogar mehr wo
nicht selten den übergang vom militär
aktiv karriere in die andere karriere
ich wirklich sehr gleitend übergangen
und auch ohne wieder einig ohne große
planegger sicher mir überhaupt keine
vorstellungen gemacht was hat nachher
werde ich bin noch gefragt wurden ob ich
vom schweizer fernsehen ich derweil als
co kommentator tätig sehen hätte damals
nicht groß was denn dass er wirklich
heißt der erste kommentar von ich bin
mit sicherheit mehr dulden ist der
cayenne mehr april die erste sendung
sein oder soll ich finde das gar nicht
geholt also dementsprechend an ich kann
nur denke du in europa knopfdruck
diskutieren wurde bin ich und wenn der
mieter trägt hat einen christus in die
welt
ja danke vielmals jahren vor die vom
staat oben aber da ist der sie die
gerichte zu diesem studio frau ist der
kombination aus abfahrt und slalom und
das wäre sie den abfahrtsski kombi
abfahrt am laubacher und zwei dosen und
dritter ist einfach zu stark man gott
direktor und shops und das ist nur ein
klacks erfahren wie viel tempo hat sie
von der sp rollt er kohle fiel natürlich
sagt sie
so kommt ins ziel mit der neuen bestzeit
und die legt um 39/100 sekunden tiefer
als die marke von carlo janka
nach olympia ich glaube das ist logisch
dass die physik ford bau von dieser
seite nicht aber irgendwie hat mich die
sättigung mit langen fluss sondern da
sind sind andere terroristen roland koch
ganz ganz wichtig sie für fortsetzung
ihrer karriere und den ich sehr schnell
der franz klammer ganz klar natürlich
gewaltige herausforderung für die ganze
reform ihrer karriere
also ist schon wieder während sony
gestartet sie auf die nächsten
olympischen spiele gut gott meine damen
und herren wie die nächsten olympischen
spiel eigentlich nicht als als
titelverteidiger gesehen dass ich mir
eigentlich nur so richtig sicher sondern
sich england ist ein neues kapitel für
mini mini karriere am start gehen
der olympiasieger von platero wenn wir
die fahrten hütten analysiert und die
sind jenseits von gut und böse sind
hälfte vor der piste über die grenze
kommen im 15 em start stopp in den augen
gestanden sorgen kann das nicht offen
[Applaus]
herrlich glaubt der kabbala der beratung
potter teil lagen zwischen sieht hin
tritt die zwischenzeiten und ich hockte
tone und habe hessen gespürt die
ersatzlose klingt gespürt wird der
berghofer zittern
in der mitte habe die leute ausgeschaut
denke man jetzt nicht irgendwas mach
dann wäre das rennen gewinnen
[Applaus]
ich bin dein ziel und konnte mich schon
gut aber das darf doch nicht machen sie
da darf das rennen für den honigtopf das
rennen nicht verliert zwar gar nicht
wählen können
das ist ganz ganz komisch kürzen
[Applaus]
frank kramer tätig mit 1 3 und liegt wie
ich im ziel war es natürlich alles über
mir eingebrochen und dann irgendwie hat
sich der bernhard durchgekämpft und hat
mir gratuliert also so eine ehrliche
gratulation habe mein ganzes leben lang
nie erfahren wo sieht man doch schon
wenn die server und dann sitzt du kannst
alles olympiasieger werden und dann
schlage ich eine andere
also doch eher schon ein herz dazu
und das ist eben der bernhard russi das
hat uns auch zu freunden machte ein
leben lang
[Musik]
ich habe eigentlich nie richtig
realisiert dass ich schon aber für user
flexibler als athlet und ich hatte mit
technischen sache wären dem kamel
sprünge schwierigkeiten mehr
attraktivität hat er sein konto und
monstern fertig hätte mich auch
kräftiger gesagt gang of calgary mit
mehr hatte das problem und sagt was gut
und was schlecht ist das denn gemacht in
den zug an tag seit gebiet steinig gut
arbeitet und ich glaube das aber hält
mich zum beispiel baut gemacht
[Musik]
es ist dem sehr schnell drauf aber auch
weil diese das heißt olympia albert wild
wo die chance zu mehr kontext los ich
bin präsident von olympische spiele ich
wollte das tapfer königsdisziplin wird
vor den olympischen spielen und ich
wollte irgendetwas machen wo die ganze
welt darüber trägt und der honig sagt ja
das machen wofür stunde befahren und
malst du über die über die fh st es war
ein großes wagnis die strecke war 1953
schon für die französischen
meisterschaften benutzt worden
ein komplettes desaster man war nicht
fähig das tempo die skifahrer zu
kontrollieren und es gab viele unfälle
ich bin der hand ich glaube es mache
aber es geht
die hat er gefunden
er hat gesagt jean claude ihr fahren wir
durch und ich du bist wahnsinnig da kann
man nicht durch und jedoch auch dass wir
werden so verlangsamen und dann so durch
also gut erste-chef vertrauen wir ihm
wir beraten sie von mir verlangt
und jetzt locker
mit zu kommen
ein ganzes gefahr dass ein kolleg sie
und das hat sich wirklich bewiesen dass
das genau 1100 verbraucht die wendepunkt
der übergang zwischen altem und modernem
skisport der liegt dort auf der strecke
von war diese
[Musik]
eine geht ist sich nicht wenige zu alles
am dresdner hof also aus so viel schnee
wie hoch verbaut mehr merkt dass man
dass man älter wird hat aber gute mixtur
wie man unbedingt mit seil und ich
glaube das wichtigste ist dass wir mehr
aufhört grenze zu ich glaube mit der
schnitt eher theoretische grenze setzte
und särge führen der 46 jährige kürzlich
das nehme also 1000 nur machen als
letztjähriger sondern müsse das machen
was mir was man immer nur luft hätte für
die grenze wo die grenzen der richtig
versteht sich automatisch gepasst sich a
[Musik]
das reizende glaube ich schon dass man
einfach immer wieder probiert ich rede
jetzt von physischer ein bewegungsmensch
von der bewegung dass man immer
liga-premiere die grenzen
die suche dort und auch damit leben dass
man den typischen mitmachen oder
vielleicht nur noch hat mache genau
gleich wie es vor grenze 21 sehe ich
dass man gewisse sachen wirtschaft
[Musik]
jetzt sind sie mache mir eigentlich nur
die jungs sind wie es hat den skisport
filme meist und xamax als eigentlich
unsere persönlichkeit den händen und
klebt und und es ist sehr glücklich dass
wir haben an gefunden hat seine
minimieren wollen oder einfach und wir
sind eigentlich glück für familie aber
die hand je länger sie mit spürt das ist
völlig irre so zweckgemeinschaft wurde
nicht mehr das realisiert haben wir
gewusst dass die vag sich sich trennen
werden und jeder phase und ich denke mal
kennengelernt wir haben bislang den
kennt ohne das typische retro wert und
sind eine sehr viel später als ich denn
das dazu entwickelt dass mehr zeit
[Musik]
wo mir den marines mit diesem nach der
blüte deutlich besser verteilt ich
erzähle der lawine ums leben den herzen
effektiv der boden unter den füßen
weggezogen
und zwar habe ich eigentlich weniger um
ich sage denken sondern denkt und musste
sich in einem kino ist
ich glaube dass sich schwierig steht
dass ich sehe es nicht die allergrößte
aufgaben
[Musik]
kastor anspruch dass sie rechts stehen
das ist alles nachher war
wenn du dann dort durch genuss
besprechen
[Musik]
der moment wo die pisten übergibt und
der erste eigentlich drüber losgeht dann
ist das kribbeln skurrile show bereits
der krise erfahrungswerten sap könnte
funktionieren aber immerhin das muss der
stand bewiesen werden und ich glaube da
bin ich schon sehr sehr nervös lx ich
bin nur der ort idee geht und die
anderen wir uns denn umsetzen und das
ich glaube eigentlich die große spende
wollen anstatt hast du die jungs
überhaupt von dir im griff ich warte
darauf die strecke muss noch freigegeben
werden
der moment vorsitzende heidrun
spätestens noch noch im ersten
trainingslauf
das ist genau bestätigung für alle
vorräte besichtigung der kurs setzt sich
probiert antrittsrede das ist schnell
der sprung ganz fit und das nicht
fahrbar
du hast habe laufen lassen ja habe ich
wenn den sänger materie vorfahren das im
gurt nicht wie in korea der dgvm zert
oder nicht endlich strom der nicht ruhig
dann geht es per funkspruch menü und
dann weiß ich jetzt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe ein großer wunsch gemüses
letzteren fall selbst am tag vor der
letzten weltmeisterschaft habe ich keine
sekunde daran denkt wenn das eigentlich
fertig sein
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
unsere weltmeisterschaft ganz oder gar
nicht ein anderer weltmeister ich auf
den sankt moritz motorik spielen kann
insofern indische gab kein problem
sitzen im auto und am rotlicht kriegs
mir wie schuppen von den augen aber und
dann frage ich mich zuerst mal mich
selber gefragt in gedanken wie lange
sich das eigentlich nur machen und wenn
ich es bis zum nächsten lehrgang und
daheim eine frau die michael fleischer
sich hören meine damen und herren guten
abend wir sind etwas traurig im
schweizer lager nicht nur weil heini
hemmi im riesenslalom achter wurde und
görlitz foyer im ersten lauf das fünfte
tor verpasst hat sondern vor allem weil
bernhard russi eben gerade um 17 uhr
seinen sofortigen rücktritt vom
wettkampfsport bekannt gegeben hat bern
az
ich denke immer muss nicht traurig sein
und scherz ist das auch kein herr er ist
so ich habe mir das sehr gut überlegt
und denke es ist das richtige für eine
crysis autosport denken und das predigen
ein prinzip punkt thomas morus und rot
teile wird die schöne momente mit ihm
können teile und das ist familie
wenn ich die größte moment die
glücklichste moment im leben denken den
meine dies ist der olympiasieger oder
weltmeister gab es sind im moment für
die geburt informieren und fototechnik
[Musik]
familie ist für mich der eigentliche
sinn von leben ich also verschiedene
arten wie sie erlaubt es uns die familie
nicht selten und wenn die familie
wohlstand mich um
gestern folgendes angebot
[Musik]
wenn ich bilanz der nachher darf ich
sage dass ich bis jetzt ist unheimlich
intensives leben hatte führen
ich habe extreme glücksmoment aber ich
kann selbstverständlich haben auch die
andere seite kennenlernen und tragische
sache schwer ist auch wo man wenn man im
moment wenn sie schon mit vielen nach
unten immer da es aber immer probiert
die positive sache im vordergrund
stellen
gerade wenn es live gegangen ist das ist
für mich sowie einen leitfaden und wenn
ich ersetze rücklagen denke sehe ich
eigentlich nur so erschien ihm im leben
[Musik]